on eight news now food trucks are among
those small businesses that have
certainly struggled during the pandemic
and the only authentic japanese food
truck in our state is based right here
in las vegas
we've got rocky theaters out there live
at the matsuri food truck with their
journey hey oh look at you you're right
inside there rocky
yes hey kirsten yeah what do you want
what was your order
yakisoba okay coming right up i got you
come on in
to my surrey food truck i'm here with
owners brittany and joseph
so we're going to make a really special
dish what's it called yakisoba right
yeah
let's talk about how this is just made
and what you guys do all right so
very first thing we're going to hit hit
the grill with some oil i like to go
ahead and do this
japanese street food festival food so
explain that to people explain that
concept yes so
it's kind of like an overlooked aspect
of japanese cuisine
um so it's a lot of the you know uh
fried noodles
fried octopus all that good stuff
um you know comfort food beer food good
yeah i love it and it's also 98 degrees
in here
so far for this community and obviously
like kristen said earlier this is the
only food truck
of its time in las vegas yep
but you guys have to go through some
things during the pandemic obviously so
let's talk about your journey
and just you know how hard it's been for
you all yeah so um
initially when coped first happened um
you know we got hit with a lot of
xenophobia unfortunately
um anybody who doesn't understand what
that means is a really strong
hate or dislike for people of a
different country right
right um and so you know since
the coronavirus had the ties to the
asian community and then we being the
only yeah good
um the only you know really asian-based
food truck
uh we got hit pretty hard uh we were
having people come up and telling us to
go back where we came from
um you know just hateful things throwing
masks at the windows
trying to get you know um so we had our
tip jar stolen at some point too
and so basically uh we made the decision
to shut down
because you know we weren't sure what
was going to happen i run the truck by
myself at night usually
and so just for safety reasons we shut
down
um we actually reopened again recently
uh and it just kind of you know it's
slow still
but it's getting there it's slow but
it's getting there and that's the kind
of progress we like to hear yeah
now we can eat and how can people enjoy
you guys
yeah so um we are we travel around here
you can find
yes uh social media instagram
facebook twitter we are under matsuri lv
and then uh live streaming on twitch as
well okay oh and coming up later in the
show we're gonna explain what that live
streaming on twitch means because that's
that's something that's really helped
you guys build back up yeah definitely
it's been a life saver it's some good
advice for small businesses coming up
later in the show i'll send it back to
you guys
don't be jealous that looks so good